oh I'm playing stream reverse chat wait
does this start off correctly someone
was asking me to play this bot earlier
who who controls the spot
oh that's so funny wait E4
chat you're you're black you're not
white so you don't control my moves but
you control I think you control
blocks moves
I think I don't know how this works
though
I hope whoever like programmed the spot
knows how to work the apis with chat and
code things so black can make a move
is my opponent gonna move though
tackling crazy
oh it made a move
open chat room
oh wow oh that's so cool
so it's kind of working
I thought this was gonna take a long
time to set up but maybe it's not
working or it's
um it's not that complicated
okay so I'm playing chat
there are 37 votes for E5
C5 was second for 14. tackling wild here
there are way to put chat above my head
ah okay so I have um
maybe where can I put chat maybe here
okay
just so if this goes on YouTube people
can
uh
see all the excitement in chat
okay
wow so everyone gets to voice their
Voice or moves
are we gonna see a staffer gamut
51 votes for Knight F6 oh dear
I feel like I've
have I been a good role model for my
audience or a bad role model
staff or Gambit time
what about Halloween Gambit time
tricks on you I'm the one playing a
gambits oh no my knight
I'll give more time yeah because it
seems like
Maybe
it requires time to process the moves
which means I'm giving time odds
basically but that's okay
now Bishop C5 would attempt to go back
into Stafford but okay Chad takes my
knight
and
[Music]
uh yeah 44 44 votes for 95.
King E7 was voted for seven times
if you're just joining the way this
works you type your move in chat for
what you want to play and then this Bots
Aggregates all the moves and plays the
most voted for a move
and so far we actually have an
interesting line of Halloween
I think black is
objectively better but
I mean these positions can get wild very
quickly
oh thank you funky donkey Happy 10
months
all right Bishop C4
so I am down at night
Chad is up at night for plan
but okay I have some nice Center
wow some people in chat know Theory
looks like there's seven trolls
saying King E7
might have to start Banning people I
don't want I don't want the my opponent
to be sabotaged by the Trolls but
there's more people actually trying to
play the best move it seems like
so D5
example I think I'll take the pawn with
Bishop
it would be cruel to
put chat in sub only mode
only Subs can vote on moves but
oh
I I'm leaving it open
so in total yeah it looks like about 50
people are voting every turn
C6 let's move back
and give a little bit more time
I'll make it so that
yeah black one flag
I'll have to play quickly
oh it's so nice that the the random
child challenge algorithm
uh match me with this opponent
I didn't realize how simple it was
this is a B4
all right Queen F3 looks fine
I like the idea of H4
I'll play H4
but H1 Waits
it was a little bit weird
because there's Knight takes H4
also don't have that much time to ponder
I'll play 0.03 with my first impression
can I flip the board do people prefer
looking from this perspective
uh no thanks I'm Gonna Keep Her This
White's perspective
are there any like close votes
oh this was very close D5 18 votes D6
was 17 votes
so I'm still down a piece
but I am threatening made in one
I wonder how many people are blundering
made in one right now
there's I saw one vote for H5
plundering F7
um
I really want to be fancy here I want to
sack the bishop
maybe now is the time for H4
or even like A4
the A4 looks nice
I'm gonna play A4
it was a very clear purpose behind this
move
realizing I have to be careful with
explaining
the secret ideas behind my moves
my opponent might be stream sniping
yeah Bishop B6 looks like it was a
pretty overwhelming vote it's a good
move
I'm hitting the queen now
should I ban my opponent for stream
sniping
if you share emotes of my face I don't
think that really counts for any move
as far as I know
oh Chad is actually playing a good game
like this is not
so simple but let's make it
a bit spicier
I want to punish the night for being
slightly exposed
okay I'll give more time I have to
really actually move faster too
[Music]
I'll play Rook B1
I do have two pawns for the minor piece
and the center but I mean black is
pretty stabilized
wow okay that move
it's a little bit feisty
I still don't have much time let's play
this
it's so fun to just look at chat and
like see what move might be coming
I actually don't know what move is
coming like so many different options
being
mentioned now
like maybe A6
all right what to do
let's play this
no it's a happy looking Bishop
I have 14 seconds left I'll give more
time have as much time as you want
oh
so I have to live on the increment
basically
maybe I should castle at some point or
maybe I should play King D2 I just want
to connect my Rooks
Knight 87 was overwhelming 19 votes
wow
hmm
oh there's really not much time okay
let's take on C6
wait does this work
well this works
I just lost another piece
it's just not gonna fall for it either
for some reason I thought this was
winning but this is not at all winning
oh dear
I'm gonna lose the chat
don't hurt me
no there's a funny line
uh Chuck
there's a crazy line oh man
okay there's one legal move
I don't think it's possible to vote for
a different move here
oh now there's two legal moves
repeat Maybe
repetition's not happening
60 votes for King yate there are only
eight votes for King C8
okay getting more time
that way people can see the the vote
stats too
um
are we gonna repeat we might end up
repeating
again there's only one legal move
I might as well pre-move
I'll pre-movework B6
I don't think it's possible for Chad to
offer a draw
I'm not sure how it works so maybe it is
or if I offer a draw I'm not sure how
how it can accept
I don't think the game is going to be
determined by draw offer
oh draw offer
13 votes for offering draw that's funny
but I played the second most voted for a
move
so I played Bishop C4 and offer to draw
oh that's kind of strange
wow
wait I have seven seconds left
I wonder if people can vote for giving
me more time
uh
let's play this
I have four pawns for two nights
what is this material imbalance
oh dear
yeah there's no option for give more
time
I have to move a lot quicker
it's so weird because it takes so long
to move and I have to like move
instantly
I'm stream sniping chat I'm trying to
see what mood is coming
I'm in trouble though
stop hurting me
some people trying to Castle
good luck with that
please stop hurting me
ah F2 is hanging uh what to do
chats played a really good game actually
it'd be funny if we get some position
where Chad has to mate with Knight and
Bishop
oh that'll be hilarious
no one only three people wanted to take
on F2 everyone wanted to take the bishop
good move
what's coming next though
also is castling is it 0-0 or 0-0
Rook H6 oh
play this move
now no more castling rights for back
this is not a comfy position
[Music]
maybe F4 the right moment
in order to for me to come back I I not
only have to trick one person I have to
trick like so many people
on the G4
interesting
three seconds
F5 may be coming
to be careful saying my ideas though
yeah five would block into Knight C4
unfortunately
a lot of people saying F6
always play F6 right
wow F6 played wait it gave me more time
wait how did I get more time
maybe the creator of the bot like gave
me more time I'm not sure
live six is a
was a nice gift
I'm not sure how much it's gonna help me
though it's still down two pieces
but two pieces for three Pawns
okay I'll get more time
that's turning into a long game
uh play F5
okay chat be careful
I have devious ideas
be very very careful
wow
yeah I don't think rookie seven was the
best move
because now
whichever way the King goes this Rook is
gonna be lost king of seven I take it
King E7
I check and eventually Win It
but it's still a fight in the end game
like it's not over
Oh no you're Rook
yeah there he goes box Rook
now anything can happen like this this
is now a three result game
not sure how I managed the trick there
and they see another draw offer wow
all right material wise
rook and do pawns for Knight and Bishop
I mean this Pawn is kind of hanging
hmm
check
that's still so much of a fight
check there
yeah maybe I shouldn't have done that
what to do
okay I'm gonna maybe win the epon
it's actually a big decision should
black keep the ephon defended
or try and blockade the f-pawn
okay I still have enough time
barely
might be winning
[Music]
might be winning the H Pawn
What's Happening Here
I didn't want to lose a g-pawn
because Rook F3 I I have Rook E3
now that actually has a lot of options
here
I'm curious what uh will be decided
ooh that's a good move
okay
man we're going very deep into the end
game
I think I can safely pre-move this
workout 3 is coming
not even close
it would be impressive if chuck could
like collectively stream snipe and play
Bishop E2 and take advantage of my
pre-move
I think I'll pre-move this
I'm basically stream or chat sniping
seeing which move is coming next
last couple moves were obvious though
Rook H3 is probably coming yeah Rook H3
is coming
but just to be safe
okay
I didn't want to pre-move H5
I'm not sure who's playing for a win
oh wait I have to move quicker
uh let's move
so I'm over defending the pawn
oh no I'm getting Forks
someone call an ambulance
how many people are gonna play Knight F3
one person says Knight F3 doesn't work
but I wonder if because they said that
does that make them vote for Knight F3
another three I'd have some Chuck
also there's some lag on my side
hope the stream's not lagging
King A5 coming
okay
confusing position
I really have to calculate on Black's
time
maybe I should look like Rook C7 not
sure though
okay H6 may be coming soon
oh no my Pawn
the rook's no longer defending
someone actually call an ambulance
but not for me
oh how many people voted 11 it was 11
11.
it was a Thai vote
wow the other option was Bishop D3
which was also actually kind of
interesting
oh
Chow resides
there is still some fight left but it is
a winning position for whites there are
eight votes for a resign
ouch I think more people were voting at
the beginning of the game and then votes
kind of dropped off what to do uh good
game if this goes on YouTube I hope
people on YouTube enjoyed this game uh
maybe some reason to follow on Twitch to
participate in in real time I'm sure
I'll do this again